- [Voiceover] So they're asking us to find
the least common multiple
of these two different polynomials.
So the first one's three z to the third
minus six z squared minus nine z
and the second is seven z to the fourth
plus 21 z to the third plus 14 z squared.
Now, if you're saying, "Well, what is a,"
you're familiar with least common multiple
of two numbers.
One way to think about them
is if I were to find, say,
the least common multiple
between, I don't know, four and six,
you literally could look
at all the multiples
and see which one is least.
So you go four, eight,
12, 16, so on and forth.
You're gonna do the same thing for six.
You'd go six, 12,
18, 24, so on and so forth.
And you immediately see that they do have,
they'll actually have
multiple common multiples,
but the least of the common multiples
you immediately see is going to be 12.
Now another way to think about it
is to actually factor these numbers out.
We could view four,
you could view four as being two times two
if we look at its prime factorization.
And six is two times three.
So you could say that the
least common multiple,
the LCM, of four and six
is going to be,
well, it's gonna be equal to,
we're gonna have to have
the factors of both of them.
So it's gonna have to have
two fours, two times two.
It's gonna have to have a two and a three.
Well we already have a two.
In fact, we have to them.
So in order to be divisible
by three, we have to be,
in order to be divisible by six,
we have to have three
as one of the factors.
And so when you look at it that way,
you say, "Hey look, we have to contain
"all of the factors of each,"
we have to have at least two twos
and we have to have at least one three
because the two twos
take care of this one too
right over there.
And you see that this is
also going to be equal to 12.
Now when we think about
it for polynomials,
we're gonna think about
it a little bit more.
It's essentially the same idea,
but we're gonna think
about it a little bit more
with the second lens.
We're gonna think about the factors
and say, well the least common multiple
needs to contain the factors of both
but it shouldn't contain more than that.
You can always find a
multiple of two polynomials
by just multiplying them,
but we don't wanna find just any multiple.
We wanna find the least common multiple.
So let's factor each of them.
So this first one, three z to the third
minus six z squared minus nine z.
Let's see. Immediately, let's see,
all of these terms are
divisible by three z,
so let's factor out of three z.
So it's three z times z squared.
We factor out of three z out of that.
See, it's gonna be minus two z
if we factor out of three z out of that.
And then minus three.
And notice, if you were to
distribute this three z back,
you would get exactly
what we have up here.
And so let's see, can
we factor this further?
Can we think of two numbers
that if we multiply, we get negative three
and if we add them, we get negative two?
And one's gonna be positive,
one's gonna be negative
since the product is negative.
So let's see. It sounds
like negative three
and positive one.
So we can rewrite this as three z
times z plus one
times z minus three.
I think I have factored
this first polynomial
about as much as I can.
One times negative
three is negative three.
One z minus three z is negative two z,
so that looks good.
So now let's factor,
now let's factor this
other character over here,
this fourth degree polynomial.
So, every one of those terms
look like they're visible
by seven z squared,
so I could write this as seven z squared
times z squared.
If we factor out of seven z squared here,
you're just left with z squared.
And then plus,
21 divided by seven is three,
z to the third divided by z squared is z.
And then plus, 14 divided by seven is two.
z squared divided by z squared is one.
So it's just gonna be a two there.
And so this is gonna be the
same thing as seven z squared.
And this can be factored into, let's see,
two times one is two,
two plus one is three.
So, z plus one
times z plus two.
Now let's think about the
least common multiple.
We've factored each of
these just the way that we,
when we did the prime
factorization for regular numbers.
Now we have factored this down
to simpler expressions
as we will find useful.
And so, the least common
multiple of these two things
has to contain each of these factors.
So the least common multiples
got to contain a three z.
It's got to contain,
and let me expand it out a little bit.
It's got to contain a three.
It's got to contain a z.
It's gotta contain a z plus one,
z plus one.
I don't have to write
the little dot there.
It's got to contain a z plus one.
It's gotta contain a z minus three.
Let's see. It's gotta contain a seven.
We do not have a seven here yet,
so we have to include a seven,
so I'll put the seven out
front with the numbers.
It's gotta include a seven.
It's gotta include a z squared.
Well we only have a z right now,
so let's throw in another z.
So I could throw in
another, I could write,
I could put a z out front
or I could just make this a squared.
It still contains that z,
but now we contain another z,
or multiplying by another
z to have z squared.
See, we already have a z plus one in here.
We need a z plus two as well,
z plus two as well.
And there you have it.
This is the least common multiple.
If I were to write it all
out in a neutral color,
it's gonna be 21 z squared
times z plus one
times z minus three
times z plus two
(chuckle) I say two and I write six.
z plus two.
And we are all done.
And I really want you to appreciate.
This is the exact same thing we're doing
when we're doing,
a very similar thing than what we're doing
when we're finding these common multiples
of regular numbers,
looking at their factors.
In the case of numbers, prime factors.
And then we say, "Okay.
The least common multiple
"has to be a superset, has
to contain all of these,
"but we don't wanna contain,"
you know, I could multiply
this times a hundred,
it's still gonna be a common
multiple of these two,
but it's no longer the
least common multiple.
Likewise, 12 is the least
common multiple of four and six.
If I just wanted a common multiple,
I can multiply that times a hundred,
1200 would also be a
multiple of four and six,
but it wouldn't be the
least common multiple,
so we don't wanna do that.
Hopefully you found that interesting.